il y avait foule pour cette séance de
dédicaces xxl neuf auteurs se sont
prêtés au jeu des signatures auprès de
leurs lecteurs dans ce magasin culturel
des clayes-sous-bois leur point commun
ils ont tous écrit des best-sellers des
polars pour la plupart ils font
également tous partie de la ligue de
l'imaginaire un collectif lancée en 2008
pour défendre la littérature de
l'imaginaire vraiment autour de ce style
littéraire parce que trop souvent on
nous parle de littérature blanche et du
reste de la littérature comme si le
reste de la littérature n'était pas
importante une littérature qui plaît à
en juger par cette file d'attenté qui
s'allongent et de minute en minute
il fallait en effet être patient pour
prendre la pose aux côtés de son auteur
préféré
ou bien pour obtenir le précieux sésame
la dédicace personnalisée très
impressionné c'est toujours quand on
passe du virtuel au réel c'est sûr
impressionnant mais voilà tu contente
bon bah on a fait le groupe id base du
premier dit qu'on adorait ce qu'il
écrivait rien de très original alors on
aimerait bien d'origine on n'en trouve
pas parce que quand on sait ce qu'il
écrivait on se dit que l'on sera pas à
la hauteur quoi composé de cinq
écrivains à sa création la ligue de
l'imaginaire compte aujourd'hui vingt
membres
plus qu'un collectif c'est une véritable
bande d'amis qui aiment se retrouver
plusieurs fois dans l'année on se limite
seulement pour certains parfois collin
qui trouve pas une idée titre ont fait
des brainstormings ensemble et on
compare nos expériences en aiment se
retrouver mon âme aussi a justement
aller dans des des salons et dans des
librairies dans des médiathèques pour
justement parler littérature
mission réussie ce samedi après midi
pour la ligue de l'imaginaire les
lecteurs friands de ce genre littéraire
ont été plus de 200 à avoir fait le
déplacement